[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's when
Senator Rafael Warnock won his runoff
election earlier this month his victory
cemented Democrats control of the U.S
Senate the Baptist pastor won his first
full six-year term after previously
winning a special election for the seat
back in 2021. now he is the first black
American to represent Georgia in the
Senate and the first black Democrat
elected to the Chamber from a Southern
state senator Warnock joins us now for
an exclusive interview on CBS morning's
Senator welcome and congratulations to
you good morning great to be here with
you so was Herschel Walker the first
call you received on Election night well
I I didn't hear from from him but listen
I'm still I'm proud of what the people
of Georgia have done yeah they certainly
came through for you they look my name
has been on the ballot five times in
less than three years
for the same doggone job clearly I
wanted this job because it allows me to
continue what's been my lifelong project
but this race seems to be we'll talk
about your your goals in a second but
the races seem to be closer than people
expected considering your opponent
considering the times what do you say
about that and Stacy Abrams did not win
the the gubernatorial seat well these
races are hard fought and it wasn't long
ago you know that we were looking at a
different situation in Georgia I'm the
first uh Democrat uh elected alongside
John ossoff in about 20 years to the
Senate and so this race is a hard fought
but we continue to build on the progress
that we've been able to make over the
years and I'm honored that I get to use
that influence that the people of
Georgia have placed in my hands you know
I think about this all the time it's
really it's an amazing thing for the
people of your state to say when we
think about our families yeah when we
look into the eyes of our children as we
try to take care of our parents as they
deal with both the blessings and the
burdens of Aging we'd like for you to
represent us uh in the senate for me
that's a sacred trust it's something I
take seriously and I'm honored to do
that clearly you keep coming back to the
job as voter suppression's still an
issue though in Georgia oh absolutely we
we should some people could say look he
won that's no longer an argument we
should not assume that because I won
that voter suppression is not an issue
in Georgia in fact I had to sue
the state of Georgia so that we could
get Saturday voting they they shortened
the runoff uh and then they said the
Saturday after a holiday which was
Thanksgiving and another Holiday by the
way that uh honored confederal
confederate general uh lee they said we
couldn't have we couldn't have Saturday
voting so I had to sue them they
appealed it took two additional appeals
to secure Saturday voting and then the
people of Georgia showed up they built a
senator a multi-racial coalition of
Consciousness
but Senator I mean it's not just some
people who could say you won so voter
suppression is not the problem it was
it's Brad rafsenberger who's the
Secretary of State of Georgia he's got
an op-ed in the Wall Street Journal out
today uh he's famed for many of our
viewers for standing up to Donald
Trump's claims of denying the election
or that the election was was stolen he's
now calling you an election denier
saying you can't say it's not a free and
fair election if you've got record
turnout what do you say to that the fact
that people have had to overcome
barriers doesn't mean those barriers
don't exist we literally saw college
students and seniors and lines that were
hours and hours and hours long
maybe he's happy with that I'm not I
think we can do better than that your
vote is your voice your voice is your
human dignity there's nothing more
sacred
than the right to vote you can have the
right to vote and still not have access
and so that's the work that I've been
doing for a long time long before I ran
for office yeah because the vote for me
as I often say is a kind of prayer for
the world we desire for ourselves and
for our children which is why I'm
focused now as a legislator on passing
voting rights in our Congress
speaking of Elections um you mentioned
during the commercial break there is a
fascination with the next election sure
do you believe that President Biden
should run for reelection in 2024. oh I
think if if he chooses to run I will
support him but I I do think we spend so
much time in our country focused on the
next election and we're not thinking
often enough about the Next Generation
yeah I was doing this work long before I
ran for office and I think that the
people are well served by politicians
are not well served by politicians who
make the politics about them of course
it ought to be about the hard-working
people of Georgia who are trying to keep
the promises that all of us make to our
children are you going to be the
president of the United States listen my
name's been on the ballot five times
in three years and so uh after that uh
I'm finally focused on being able to do
the work the people of Georgia have
elected me to do in addition to that
I've got two children at home yeah a
little little guys let's talk about a
trip to Disney World well I think you
can deliver on that let's talk about the
January 6 committee is ready it seems to
recommend that Donald Trump be
prosecuted to be held accountable what
do you think should happen there I know
it's it's a recommendation and it's
their decision but what do you think
should happen I think we are a nation of
laws and not of men
and so uh it's important that we protect
our election system again the people of
Georgia sent me to the Senate alongside
John also the first African-American and
first Jew on January 5th on January 6 we
saw the most violent assault that we've
seen since the War of 1812 on our
Capital driven by the big lie we all saw
it so you think he should be prosecuted
I think that this committee has done
excellent work and I've been that's a
yes or no question Senator yes sir I'm
saying that we as they refer to the
Department of Justice we want to allow
the Department of Justice to do its work
all right and and no one should be above
the law nobody
uh on the border right now uh the
administration is warning of a potential
increase in the already increased
numbers of people showing up because of
a title 42 expiring title 42 is allows
the government to expel migrants for um
for public health reasons uh do you
think it's a mistake given the lack of
resources on the border given the crush
of people coming to let it expire do you
think we need title 42 to control the
Border I think it's important to secure
the border which I've always said
and I think it's important that people
have a dignified orderly path to
citizenship which I've always said we
are a nation of immigrants
and I think it's only politics
that creates this false choice between
securing the Border yeah and giving
people a dignified path to citizenship
and by the way doing something about the
dreamers
uh for whom this is the only country
they've ever known and those who are
dealing with temporary protective status
right now I think we can do both of
those things at the same time we need
comprehensive immigration reform in this
country I know we've been saying that
we've been saying that for years and
years and years and that never changes
can you imagine well so far it hasn't
changed can you imagine a scenario where
we say look I'm so sorry we just can't
help you we don't have the resources we
don't have the spaces we don't have the
manpower to help can you can you
envision that I think we are a nation of
immigrants and we always will be we are
great not in spite of our diversity but
because of it and again we can secure
the Border we have to make sure that we
don't make a humanitarian crisis at the
board a worse
while at the same time we can forge a
path I believe a bipartisan path you do
to getting immigration reform done in
our country and
um people who are in business farmers
and folks in the agriculture sector and
other sectors know that that we've got
to do these things yeah and I remain
focused on it Senator Warnock you don't
have to run for anything now for six
years
otherwise I'm running to Disney World
with my two little children here it is
but before that I'm going to take a nap
all right we got a comfortable couch
tonight
thank you very much appreciate it